Speaker 1: So one of the things that will
often happen when there is what we would call
sort of like a saturation coverage story,
where with the verdicts yesterday in the Derek
Chauvin case, basically every news channel
was covering it live.
Right wing media essentially has no choice
but to cover it.
There's lots of stories that right wing media
will just ignore.
But when you have like a saturation story,
typically right wing media has to cover it.
And often that leads to completely unhinged
meltdowns and lots of really funny things.
So let's go through a few things that happened
yesterday in the hours following the three
guilty verdicts for Derek Shervin in the killing
of George Floyd.
Here is Greg Gutfeld.
I guess now he's a comedy host.
I guess he's a comedian.
I don't know.
He has a comedy show now on Fox News.
He seemed to almost completely become unglued
when a Fox News guest called out Gutfeld for
his comments on the verdict.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 4: Now, I got to tell you, I heard
Greg a few minutes ago, and I got to tell
you, I don't know.
Greg is off his meds if he believes excuse
me was not.
Excuse me.
What did you say?
What did he say?
I am I haven't been, like, not around here.
Let's face if you do not believe that there
was evidence.
I didn't say it does support the I got a bridge
in Brooklyn to spare you.
Speaker 1: Isn't that something just everybody
losing their minds yesterday on right wing
media.
Here is a daily wire host saying and it's
just so weird because these are supposedly
the due process and law and order people.
Here's a daily wire host saying the only verdict
we could have trusted would be not guilty.
Anything else is not trustworthy.
Speaker 2: What take a look at hours after
the judge in the case reprimanded Maxine Waters,
who flew from D.C. to the city before the
jury had started deliberating to demand a
certain guilty verdict.
In fact, she demanded a verdict on premeditated
murder, which she wasn't even charged with.
And first of all, that whole Maxine Waters
going to Minneapolis, what else could that
be other than an attempt to intimidate and
tamper with the jury?
What other motivation could you have to fly
as a high ranking politician to the city where
this local murder trial is happening and demand
that the jury come to a verdict?
Either you believe in fair trials or you don't
either you want the jury to weigh the evidence
and come to a decision or you don't.
It's clear that they don't hear the problem.
The irony is that the only.
Verdict we could really trust is an acquittal
on all counts.
I think that would have been the right verdict,
but it's also the only one you can trust because
it's the only one that couldn't have been
motivated by anything but a look at the evidence.
Speaker 1: And he says, hey, look at the evidence.
Could only lead to not guilty by this is like
a no true Scotsman fallacy.
Guilt by definition, according to this guy,
means the jury did not look at the evidence.
What happened to these people?
What happened to due process and respecting
the process we have for jury selection and
a judge deciding what evidence is admissible
and is not what happened.
It's almost like they really never believed
it.
They just would would go with it if it helped
them.
This next one's really good.
As Ben Shapiro, Ben Shapiro after the verdict
says, by the way, is there any evidence that
this was a racial killing?
And, of course, what does that have to do
with the charges?
It has nothing to do with the charges.
Take a look.
Speaker 2: Well, both of those speeches were
about how America is racist.
Again, where is the racial component?
And that's where is it like?
Has anyone yet provided any shred of evidence
to suggest that it was racial killing, wasn't
it?
No, none.
And then not only that, you have Joe Biden
out there saying that America's police, all
of our systems are actually systemically racist.
Speaker 1: The guilty verdicts are four charges
that do not mention race.
They were based on the facts of the case.
Here's one more can to clip.
We looked at her appearance with Tucker earlier.
Here's Candice Owens hanging out with the
daily wire guys pointing out that really this
is about George Floyd being a drug addict.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: This is literally a drug addict.
Speaker 5: Drug addict who was he abused?
Women.
He abused man.
He you know, this is this is disgusting.
That is it actually grosses me out.
Do we have no better examples to put forward
in the black community?
When you think of the word justice, you think
of George Floyd.
I mean, how far we have fallen since Martin
Luther King
Speaker 1: just grasping at straws.
They have no idea what to do with themselves.
Going now from Fox News and Daily Wire to
Newsmax, here is a Newsmax host saying that
the jury sacrificed Derek Shoven to the mob.
Speaker 2: It's pressure on the scale, right?
I mean, they say justice is blind.
I don't think it was blind in this case at
all.
I think he had political pressure.
I think he had pressure from all these activist
groups going into all this.
And I think at the end of the day, people
say, you know what, if we acquit this guy,
this city is going to burn to the ground.
It is going to burn to the ground.
So you had a jury that said, you know what,
we're going to have to sacrifice this guy
to the mob.
And that's exactly what I think happened today.
Speaker 1: This was not, according to this
Newsmax host, jurors looking at the evidence
and deciding guilty or not guilty, it was
jurors sacrificing Derek Chauvin to the mob
immediately after the guilty verdict.
Newsmax host also saying it was not a fair
trial.
Speaker 2: What happens tonight?
We don't know.
I mean, obviously right now it's still light
outside.
There's a lot of security around there.
You've got a group of people, I would assume
that's some members of the family, Floyd,
the friends of Floyd.
They're celebrating.
We don't know what this turns into as night
falls again is sometimes there's no appeasing
a mob in a situation like that.
We don't we have three guilty counts.
The first thing that I thought of in my head
was, you know, and we talked a lot about this
with Dershowitz, Alan Dershowitz, how on earth
was he expecting to get a fair trial in this
thing?
There was a tremendous amount of pressure
on that jury.
I mean, you would have had to have been out
of your mind to vote to acquit this man, knowing
full well that everybody is going to figure
out who you are and you're going to have the
likes of BLM and protesters coming after you
with everything they got.
If you're the one person that says, oh, no,
I think he was innocent, I think George Floyd
probably had a pocketful of drugs when the
cops came up to him.
He had a bad heart.
They put him on the ground.
If he hadn't done those things, he might have
had a stiff neck the next day, but he died
instead.
Speaker 1: I like how it's totally peaceful,
but he still has to say, well, you know, it's
light out right now.
It'll probably get really dangerous when it's
dark out.
And of course, it didn't.
And of course, the things that the host is
proposing were debunked in the trial by medical
experts.
So, yes, it's pathetic.
And it is unfortunate that so many people
are already repeating these lines with absolutely
no critical thinking applied whatsoever.
And there is one more that I'm going to play
for you.
After the break, because it actually deserves
its own segment, it is Tucker Carlson appearing
to have a psychotic break and kicking his
guests off air when talking about the verdict.
So right after this short break, we'll jump
into that and we will have more of these clips
on our Instagram page.
You can find us on Instagram at
David Pakman show.